so congress has allocated another 14
billion dollars in u.s tax money to
secure the border of ukraine so it
seemed like a good moment to check in on
our southern border fox's bill malugion
has done better reporting on this
question than anyone in media he joins
us tonight how's it going down there
bill
not good tucker fiscal year 2021 we all
know set the all-time record at our
southern border with 1.7 million
encounters with illegal immigrants but
so far this year fiscal year 2022 it's
already blowing those last year numbers
completely out of the water take a look
at this video given to me by a source in
the rio grande valley this week what
you're looking at is a group of illegal
immigrant runners evading after they
crossed illegally in mission texas
unclear if they were ever caught then
what you're going to see here is a photo
compilation of different incidents on
different border patrol sectors all over
our southern border different parts del
rio sector big bend sector tucson
arizona sector large groups of illegal
immigrants being apprehended and
arrested by border patrol single adults
families and runners dressed in
camouflage actively trying to get away
then we talk about the criminal elements
take a look at this mug shot right here
del rio sector border agents reporting
yesterday they arrested this convicted
murderer from el salvador his victim was
an eight-month-old baby he was arrested
near brackettville texas then circling
back to the huge numbers i want to talk
about a dhs source telling me that just
since october 1st just in the rio grande
valley sector alone border patrol has
already encountered nearly 212 000
illegal immigrants that is a 92 percent
increase over the same time last year
they've encountered almost 31 000
unaccompanied minors that's up 185
percent and they've encountered almost
67 000 family units that is a 206
percent increase and again we're only
talking about one of the nine border
patrol sectors at our southern border
then let's take a look at the bigger
picture nationwide this year as i
mentioned crushing last year's numbers
in fiscal year 2021 between october and
january there were just under 297 000
illegal immigrants encountered at our
southern border this fiscal year between
october and january there have already
been nearly 673
000 encounters with illegal immigrants
that's more than double last year at the
same time it's a 126 percent increase
and we've not even gotten to the busy
springtime months yet and tucker perhaps
most concerning about all this a very
high-level dhs source tells me that just
since october 1st there have already
been more than 220 000 known godaways
that are aborted those are people that
border patrol maybe see on cameras or
sensors but they just don't have the
manpower to get to so we're talking
nearly a quarter million people who have
snuck past our border in just over four
months
send it back to you
14 billion for ukraine's borders nothing
to secure ours bill militia i appreciate
you coming on tonight thank you thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else